ladies and gentlemen five-time nominee
to
Academy Award winner Miss Olivia de
Havilland
thank you very much as an actress I've
spanned eight centuries on the screen
from Robin Hoods England through the
Civil War to the present day all of us
who have traveled through history in the
moons are especially indebted to the art
director he is the artist who magically
evokes for us a particular time and
place
I am honored to present the award for
best achievement in art direction
the nominees are the last emperor art
direction set direct decoration by bruno
chaser and Osvaldo days ago Radio Dame's
art direction by santol Acosta setback
decoration by Carol Chopin
resolute that's bill and George the Tita
Jun open floor art direction
our collection by Antony that set
decoration by Joel fuller The
Untouchables art direction by Patrizia
Varnum brandenstein
and we do a very set decoration by how
goes
Empire of the Sun art direction by
Norman Reynolds set decoration by
Harriet Porter the women is feared anon
discussion
actually that's plenty
thank you I wish to dedicate this award
to the memory of Bruce Weintraub Alan
Stern and Cathy English I wish they were
here tonight I also would like to thank
my art directors Johnnie driven Unni
Giovanni Silvestri and Maria Theresa
barbasco who for some reason could not
be nominated and a special thank to
Bernardo for his incredible faith in
this project and thank you all